nous sommes à une vingtaine de
kilomètres seulement de Carson et comme
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi les
équipes de déminage sont en plein
travaux c'est le plus gros chantier qui
attend les autorités ukrainiennes dans
cette région pour sécuriser notamment
cette route qui relie Carson au reste du
pays
le déminage des infrastructures aussi
est en cours pour la bonne raison que
l'hiver approche il va faire extrêmement
froid c'est pourquoi nous devons régler
cela pour rétablir l'électricité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons 25 unités qui travaillent en
ce moment 90% du travail est fait
manuellement car nous n'avons pas assez
d'équipements adéquats d'équipements
robotique
des techniques qui pourraient nous
permettre de travailler plus rapidement
de façon plus sûre pour nos hommes ainsi
que pour la population
les trains reliant mikolaïa avec Herson
devait reprendre leur activité cette
semaine mais les autorités ont décrété
que le terrain était trop miné auprès
des chemins de fer donc par mesure de
sécurité cela va prendre un petit peu
plus de temps les autorités nous ont
également affirmé que la région de
Carson était le terrain le plus minet de
toute l'Ukraine